when it's in trouble for saying this but
sometimes I try to just drink coffee in
the morning and like you can start I do
my Hunger I do that too but we all do it
yeah she just says it
um no I'm pretty sure we don't all do
that picking up really hungry and then
purposefully suppressing that hunger
with coffee is not normal or healthy
it's legit disordered eating and if
you're someone that does that regularly
and it works for you cool but as an
influential person like why are we not
thinking twice about the messages that
we share with young impressionable fans
online do we want young people to think
it's a good idea to just drink a ton of
coffee until the hunger pangs go away I
would way rather them lie about to the
public than to teach young people that
we all do it like that to me is really
up but let me know in the
comments what you guys think should
celebrities be more transparent about
some of their more problematic eating
behaviors or should they be lying to
protect some of their young impressional
fans I want to hear what you guys have
to say